I grew up in Estonia
under Soviet occupation.
In a country locked up
behind the thick wall of the Iron Curtain.
Back then, where everything,
including bread, socks
and underwear was a luxury,
I did not dream about the open world.
Because you see,
some walls are so thick
and borders so closed,
that even dreams and ideas can't travel.
However, having lived in that level
of darkness made me wonder
why are borders and movement
between countries
constructed the way they are.
According to the World Economic Forum,
human capital is the driving force
for economic growth.
So why are the barriers
to global mobility so high?
Why is the process so time-consuming,
so dreadful and daunting, so very scary?
And I know it’s scary,
because I was detained
at San Francisco airport for two hours
just to get on the stage.
It was the idea
that the cross-border movement of people
shouldn't be so difficult
that sparked my inspiration
for a future of frictionless,
borderless mobility for all,
regardless where they are born.
We are building a universal
digital identity
for cross-border movement.
One where people own their data
and can seamlessly relocate
anywhere they want
with minimal friction.
One which would eventually
allow individuals,
from highly-skilled professionals
to refugees seeking safety,
to start, track and get approval
for their immigration process
without having to print out
a single piece of paper.
And we are not alone.
Companies and countries around the world
have started to leverage technology
in order to ease the complexity
of immigration.
By doing so, we are expanding
opportunities across borders
and through that,
helping to build a richer world.
In 2017, the Economist magazine stated
there's one seemingly simple policy
that would make the world
twice as rich as it is.
Open borders.
Economist Michael Clemens
from the Center of Global
Development seems to agree
as he claims that barriers to immigration
place one of the fattest of all wedges
between humankind's current welfare
and potential welfare.
But you know what?
The problem starts
from what we call a passport,
which was first introduced
as a globally required travel document
during World War I,
slightly after Henry Ford introduced
the first affordable automobiles.
Today, our cars have come a long way.
We have come from model Ts to Teslas.
But our passports look and work
pretty much the same way as a century ago.
Besides the lack of technology,
there was also a flaw in the way
the passport system was built.
The modern passport was designed
by a Western-centric organization
after the First World War.
It became an object of freedom
for the advantaged,
mostly Western countries,
but a burden for others.
The irony is that today
the passport doesn't even help
those same Western economies anymore,
because you see, when in the past
a good passport could indicate
a person coming from a Western country
with a good education system
and thus useful skills,
then in 2020, the World
Economic Forum reported
that the top three countries
where the highly educated
migrants came from
were India, China and Philippines.
Which, according to 2021
Henley Passport Index
ranked among the least travel-friendly
passports in the world
ranking respectively 85th,
70th and 77th out of 110.
So let's take a look at a recent
relocation experience
by a highly skilled specialist
called Ibtehal.
Ibtehal is a divorced single mother
with full custody rights for her kids,
six-year-old boy Kenan
and an eight-year-old girl Tamara.
All of them are Yemeni citizens,
which, according to Henley
Passport Index 2021,
ranks 106 out of 110.
Again, one of the least travel-friendly
passports in the world.
The Malaysian tech company
that employed Ibtehal
wanted to transfer her and her family
to their European office.
The immigration authorities let her know
that her visa would get approved,
but her underage kids
would not get their visas right away.
Instead, she was required to travel
6,000 miles alone to the embassy
to apply for her visa.
Then travel back to Malaysia,
wait for three months,
then travel back again,
this time with her kids
to apply for their visas.
And only after that could they all go
and live in the destination country.
Stories like this are not the exception.
It is a pretty accurate reflection
of the immigration experiences today,
and this is exactly the kind
of hideous problem that I want to solve.
And I know it can be solved
because I have seen
the Estonian society transform
from one of the poorest
countries in the world
to an open and democratic one
that not only functions but thrives
as a poster child for technology-driven
governance and innovation.
One of the keys to Estonia's success
in digitalization was the focus
to build one platform called the X-Road,
the backbone of digital Estonia.
The key to it is one digital identity
for each individual
that allows public and private databases
to link up and operate in harmony.
Estonians can do everything online,
other than get married or divorced.
Anything from doing taxes
to voting in the elections
is securely done online
and takes about the same time
as checking your Instagram account.
The digitalization saves Estonia
a stack of paper
as high as the Eiffel Tower every month.
On top of that, according to Siim Sikkut,
the chief information officer of Estonia,
the digital signature alone
enables Estonia to save
two percent of its GDP every year.
Two percent of GDP globally
would be 1.7 trillion dollars.
With that amount of money,
we could solve world hunger not once,
56 times every year.
That's a whole lot of money being wasted
because public sectors are not adapting
to existing technologies.
We can tackle that by creating a secure,
universal digital identity
where all the users need to do
is upload their data and documents
such as passport, marriage
and education certificates
into our smart system,
which then converts that data into pieces
that can be matched to relevant
government forms in different countries.
The beauty of it is the once-only rule.
The user needs to add their data once
as it is then stored for the future use.
The passport was created
as a mechanism to move.
It is clearly time
to modernize that mechanism.
If we could now connect
that same digital identity
to government systems worldwide,
our system could act as a digital passport
and with a click of a button,
immigration applications are created,
submitted and digitally tracked.
Imagine never to have to fill
any immigration forms ever again.
In order for that to happen,
we need government immigration systems
to enable a simple integration,
which would allow us to push applications
and pull back the status.
Today, our system is able to do
all that beautiful automation,
but to get that digital information
to government systems worldwide,
ton of paper needs to be printed out
and a human at an immigration office
needs to type everything in again.
In Germany, officials are so busy
typing in applications
that it can take up to a year
to even get an appointment,
at a time where Germany is experiencing
a deep talent crunch.
That is not just an inefficient system,
not a harmless bit of bureaucracy,
it is actively working against itself.
Four years ago, when traveling
to New York City from Europe
with my then four-year-old daughter Maya,
I briefed her what to expect
at the border and why.
When we finally got to the border,
this was her look
that the machine captured.
(Laughter)
I think it was the most
authentic look how we humans feel
about immigration globally.
(Laughter)
Last year, through a small digitalization
with Berlin immigration authorities,
my team managed to shorten a process
that was 90 days into two days.
Think about what a person
can do in 88 days.
Your passport describes you
as a resident of your country.
We say you're a citizen of the world.
A universal digital passport,
one that would go beyond borders,
will take us towards a world
where crossing borders
is not about waste of time
or waste of resources.
Think about these 88 days
and how much actual life can fit into it.
Thank you.
(Applause)